it's that time again to talk to you
about latest games in new releases and
this week we get a little surprise from
a small team of developers at Ubisoft
and it's called grow home what began as
a fun side project inspired by wally and
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy is now
grown into a full game coming to PC you
control bud or botanical utility droid
to assist growing a star plant to help
oxygenate his world but as the star
plant grows up words but must travel to
the clouds to get the seeds even if it
means a long way down if he happens to
fall do the robot on the fourth but if
you feel like saving some money this
week consider grabbing I darb for Xbox
one because it's free to anyone with
gold also known as it draws a red box
this game is part platformer part hockey
part fighting game and part party game
that will surely make you fight with
your loved ones and ruin any established
relationships you've worked so hard to
maintain also did you know Tim Schafer
is a playable character become the shape
on the first the developers of the
critically acclaimed capsized are added
again with apathy on this 2d action RPG
is set in ancient Greek mythology making
it look like you're playing from the
side of an antique Vaz climb Mount
Olympus and save mankind from the dodds
you'll find all sorts of various weapons
to try as you explore this beautifully
decrepid world it's coming to PC but you
can get it for free in the month of
februari if you've got PlayStation Plus
not a bad call take down the gods on the
third also this week you travel to a
pineapple under the sea with SpongeBob
hero pants in the game SpongeBob's
dreams are coming to life altering
bikini bottom based on his
manifestations just imagine how
different Michael Crichton's sphere
would have been if spongebob was there
play a spongebob Patrick Squidward sandy
mr. Krabs or even the villainous
plankton to explore weird underwater
environments and you know when I say
weird it's going to be really really
weird start flipping Krabby Patties on
the third
finally Game of Thrones a telltale Game
series gets its second episode this week
following the events that took place
after the very first episode but I don't
want to give anything away so I'm just
going to end the video here for further
details visit gamespot com release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week it
doesn't matter what you feel it only
matters what you say